by the way I didn't know the good nurse
was a true story until the very end and
my sister and I were like what
I didn't know it was a true spoiler
alert
um but it's a it's a true it's already
out there I just was an idiot and didn't
know and I was just like what so but
it's cool though that you get to tell
people stories I think that's powerful
able to use your platform like that
because that impacts people art impacts
people in a different way it does seeing
it on the news like wanting to know
women's stories you know in the history
books I wasn't really learning about
women's heroicism and and women are
superheroes yeah and so learning about
all these true stories of these
incredible women and especially Amy
loughran I love to be able to use my
profession to go oh hey you guys you
know I know there's all these other
superheroes out there but look at this
woman right here and we could all be
like that and we could all be inspired
by her no literally it blew my mind when
I found out it was real at the end I
didn't know I literally went into it
blind I didn't know what the plot I had
no idea and you know
um a lot of kids you know exaggerated in
Hollywood and I don't want to give any
spoilers but the last scene in the movie
really happened it wasn't exaggerated
and our Philippine fate and our our film
really is you know the media there's a
lot of teaching the lesson of using
violence to stop violence you know you
always see them going out there chasing
the bad guy with the gun and like
there's a shootout and then you get the
bad guys our story really was like well
what happens if this woman uses
compassion and empathy and reminds
someone that he's a human being when
other people are treating him as a
monster and that compassion is what
stops the cycle of violence and that
empathy is the superpower exactly being
empathetic
so many messages there for all of us to
learn obviously but you two are
incredible I mean I love you separately
but like it was like
it was like a master class in acting
like even what your character is going
through physically like while having
this whole story happen and her family
and and being a single mom it was just a
lot yeah and I just I found it
incredible yeah so Amy's a single mom
two daughters and I mean this is all
true story she had suffered from
cardiomyopathy which means she needed a
heart transplant and she was working as
a Night Nurse her heart was not allowed
to go above a certain beats per minute
and all this is happening being a nurse
is a very physical job people
underestimate that you're constantly
carrying people and turning them and you
know you're running and doing
compression compressions are very
physical and that was actually that was
the best part for me is that when nurses
saw the film they said you got the
compressions right because I mean we
went to nursing school Eddie and I and I
guess you know the whole thing a lot of
times in movies you see people bend
their wrists
exactly yeah yeah which I have so much
of so that's why it was helpful yeah but
also your number four in your mind the
whole time that you're doing
compressions think
staying alive oh my God are you alive
yes and that's the beat of the
compression oh my God I didn't know that
so everyone my teacher did not teach me
that yeah but that's the B that's that's
how you're supposed to oh my gosh yeah
look what you just taught us the more
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
all right I'm going home